Let's uh let's switch gears a little bit
you were on the cover of the show
tell me about that like how did that
come about when you found out you're
going to be on the cover of the show I
heard that you threw your dog
oh and well he landed in the pool he
landed in the pool up in there dog
probably didn't deserve that he loves
the pool though oh okay okay I thought
you just dogged and he was he was just
sitting down laying down chilling it was
like in my life he's small he's small
okay okay the little ones in my life we
were just outside chilling the little
one was in my lap the big one is on the
ground I'm not picking up the big one
like he just jumps in the pool okay so
y'all went I mean they went though they
went yeah so I'm not that big of a pool
guy all right so tell me about it so
tell me about it when you find out
you're gonna be on the show yeah like
what was going through your mind bro it
was just like bro I literally was
talking about this all year like this is
crazy like and I didn't even get to play
the whole year last year like all I did
was get to the All-Star Game and like
became All-Star and like
really for me it was like dang like
that's is that all it takes to get there
and I like honestly like me being real
with myself I thought last year was
trash too even though it was 60 games
like I think I'm only at 60 games this
year and have the exact same numbers so
like when I think of it it's still like
trash to me because it's like
if I can just stay healthy and keep
playing
you could get a lot more out of just
that you know I mean like even though
this is like a dream come true
like in my head it was just like wow I
didn't even play well last year you know
you're on the cover and I'm on the cover
so
I just feel like there's a lot to take
out of that you know for me